why is the US sending so much money to
Ukraine hint it's not because they care
about the Ukraine people it's because
it's a great way to drain Russia's
military and resources while not having
to fight the war themselves think about
it the longer America drags out this war
with Ukraine and Russia the more Putin's
wallet is going to be drained the more
Russian soldiers are gonna suffer while
at the same time America gets to test
out new weapons against their adversary
they get to refine those weapons they
get to practice their ability to move
massive amounts of a military equipment
around the world this is a golden
opportunity that America just can't pass
up which is why